like like I I remember it was around
2019 it was right before 2020 started me
and Ryan were like man we are burnt the
[ __ ] out you know I was like yeah just
about to hit like 30 and I was like bro
I don't wanna I don't wanna do this as
much as I'm doing this anymore I don't
want to go like travel and have a good
time just relax let's get a dog let's
hang out with my parents
um the pandemic said everybody take a
break
so it I remember just very vividly being
like I am one thousand percent burnt out
yeah and I cannot do this anymore yeah
and I had to I had to push pause and now
only after everything like two or three
years I'm like okay can go do it again
five day Speed Build I might just do a
devious leak into 10 30 calls again you
know you know how it is if you went to a
convention what were you doing
throughout the pandemic just chilling oh
yeah I just feel like any side benches
or anything yeah I uh a lot of stuff off
uh like like we're we're getting into
building a little we're gonna like start
building Hobbit holes and creating like
what is
like like from one of the Rings you're
gonna make one of those yeah we're gonna
we're gonna get
and we're gonna build Hobbit holes and
like fantasy cabins and like build this
like uh almost like an Airbnb situation
where our friends can come and just like
stay make content or whatever and then
we're gonna like like become little old
cabin mushroom people
that sounds like an awesome project I'm
like really excited Ryan turned our
front room into a d d Tavern wow yeah
about it
but uh he's like he's been really really
keen on doing like a bunch of like
Woodwork and all that kind of stuff so
like that's what we really want to do
yeah it definitely seems like a woodwork
kind of guy he gives off woodwork energy
what do you what do you guys want to do
like Beyond
beyond
beyond what Beyond this Dimension that's
a good question I feel like I'm showing
the in the thick of it right now I'm
just like I'm I'm just yeah bad [ __ ] God
damn it I [ __ ] hate that Tick-Tock
noise
I'm like in the middle of it right now
I'm really enjoying it and I feel like I
don't want to do anything else right now
yeah that's what I like doing yeah right
right now like pretty much all of our
three schedules are like packed yeah
like with everything that we're working
on I don't have time to think about what
I want to do next because I'm kind of
kind of doing it now meanwhile I just
started a clothing thing and I'm
dreading the fact that like my work has
just tripled but it's so fun
yeah but it's so fun and it's like yeah
it's worth it like yeah now I have less
free time than ever now but it's like
yeah it's cool to do something that's
just like completely different now yeah
you definitely have to change gears when
you're in the space too because it can
make you really like you don't want to
start getting um what's it called when
you stagnating anything you stagnate but
also like like you don't want to be
angry at what you're doing yeah you have
to change gears and do I just don't want
to be in like a monotonous cycle yes
yeah absolutely with like everything
like I don't want to get to the point
where it's like I know what I'm gonna be
doing for the next six days because it's
going to be exactly the same as what I
did today exactly I don't want to get to
that point so it's like yeah like this
year is like by far the busiest year of
my life he's like it's like not even not
even a comparison here like it it feels
weird that like you know normally
normally when you get married that's
like that's like everything revolves
around that for the entire time to
settle down yeah you found yourself down
to me like marriage my marriage is
obviously an amazing event but it was
like only one of the things that were
planned in this like [ __ ] massive
area
um like check that off the list let's
see what else we got left right ask me
again in the year and I'll probably have
a better answer yeah yeah I'm always
really curious to see what other content
creators are doing with their lives
beyond like the content right because
it's right I can't see
camera and being like
next time you know like yeah you know
YouTubers doing their thing but like but
then there's that cute guy that plays
RuneScape on Twitch yeah I was gonna say
this yeah the old guy and if it makes
him happy then you can do it you know
yeah so I'm like I'm really really
interested to see like I I've been
watching Felix's videos since he's been
yeah yeah yeah and there's just such a
feeling of like oh hell yeah dude he's
enjoying it so [ __ ] much he's making
Vlogs again and I'm like I'm so happy
for him you know he's just doing it with
his iPhone
yeah well because like I feel like
another big thing is that the past two
years have been the pandemic so I feel
like it you either went one of two ways
you either like really just use that
time to like chill out and start doing
some side gigs or some side projects uh
or for us we just kind of filled that
kind of void with just keeping ourselves
busy to like distract ourselves with how
depressing it was to not be able to see
our friends and stuff like that uh and
now we're just like kind of getting out
of that endemic and we kind of realize
holy [ __ ] we are so [ __ ] busy and we
gave ourselves this schedule in order to
distract ourselves originally yeah and
now we're like traveling and doing all
this other stuff as well so cool I think
it's so awesome I think it's like it's
so deserved like you guys created such
an incredible podcast for people to kind
of like lean on during like the pandemic
and everything and like the people that
follow you and everything you probably
feel just I'm sure I speak for them in
the way that they probably just
appreciate the ever loving [ __ ] out of
what you guys have done we just talked
[ __ ] for two hours bro
that's all we do it's so nice this is
the easy part of our job exactly let's
not talk about our main Channel stuff
yeah right that's the hard part we just
wear stupid hats oh [ __ ] you know that's
all we do
yeah so like do you plan to go back to
more conventions now that you know
everything's opening back up again so I
really want to start doing stealthy
costumes like make full-on like
unrecognizable yeah like either like
like Go full on like uh do you know
Ariel from Diablo uh
[Music]
that I'm doing too hard
so you're gonna do like the Adam Savage
thing where he's just like
non-recognizable cosplay just just stuff
that like is purely like if people want
to stop and take photos it's because
they're like wow your costume is [ __ ]
sick yeah and then like that's like the
the soul of it and everything because I
still do love making stuff I got really
into making uh fairy houses
like just little fairy homes what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah it's like small
homes like little tiny houses like I
made tiny houses out of like sticks and
like mushrooms and stuff and I got I got
this how does one get into that
a pandemic how does how does one
discover that to begin with I got
hardcore into like just like beaches and
stuff yeah like tiny little like I would
make little tables and chairs Ryan I've
shot cooking math all right
so I started making fairy houses guys
doing this so therapeutic I loved it
it's like all the people who started
knitting you know I got really into
plants so every time I got really
depressed
into plants as well yeah whatever it was
like a huge fairy garden room now and I
was like everyone turned into her
everyone turned into a plant mom during
the day yeah yeah yeah and then oh my
gosh yeah so like that's kind of like
where the thing is like the fairy house
is kind of like blend into like The
Hobbit holes and like all right right
creating stuff is still something I want
to do in the future but just like maybe
not necessarily like in front of the
camera yeah it makes sense just to like
make stuff I think I remember you were
telling me all Aki oh because I think we
just in a casual conversation we had a
similar like conversation asking like
what would you want to do after
cosplaying yeah right because it's like
you know I think it goes without saying
that like cosplaying in retrospect
doesn't have as long of a lifespan yeah
for people right especially because you
know once people start to get a little
bit older it gets a little more
difficult to cosplay certain characters
right so it's like but I think I
remember and correct me if I'm wrong in
this but you were like I want to get
into like a manager like type position
where you like manage cosplayers and
stuff like that yeah there was a time
where I was thinking about that and then
I was like that's [ __ ] stupid
and I was like oh do I really want to
manage people and I was like maybe I
could like fund a management company and
then like have people that like want to
do it like for like for sure but like oh
okay because I'm glad you said that now
because I remember when you told me that
time I responded to being like yeah that
sounds like a great idea but they might
have like she can't be a [ __ ] message
not me bro
dude that's not you no I don't want to
manage people right yeah
how'd you feel like the cosplay season
has changed since you started oh my gosh
um Tick Tock has made it so huge did you
do Tick Tock as well not really I have a
little Tick Tock it's got like a hundred
thousand people on it but like it's
mostly just like Kato and then like yeah
it's really fun like travel videos yeah
yeah but um no I think Tick Tock is I
I love Tick Tock and I love consuming to
talk I don't want to create Fork Tick
Tock right because I want it to be this
pure like untempered like meme stream
that I can just kind of like go and like
enjoy you don't want to ruin the
platform for yourself yeah exactly like
I don't want to look at it and be like
oh I don't want to go on Tick Tock
because I have to create for it you know
I just don't know what I would create
yeah I feel like you guys could do the
you guys could do the cool little like
stream stream clip things yeah we do
that already yeah we do that for trash
taste but it's like for me personally
I'm like I don't know what I would do I
actually was my personal streams oh okay
that makes it works pretty well yeah
that's awesome that's the way to grow
these days Tick Tock is like the the
Avenue gotta be on there yep that's the
Hat that's how you do it the Zoomers are
got it the kids
I'm so grateful for Zoomers they've like
no I tell you man they like being in a
being in the space like with Zoomers and
like
um
yeah yeah so like being in the like
creative space with Zoomers and
Millennials and stuff like that is
really interesting because they can
teach us so many things and they can
keep us like on top of our [ __ ] and they
can also like motivate the crap out of
you yeah yeah it's what you're doing you
know it might have the enthusiasm that
you lost over the years yeah
I had that one day yeah I remember I
remember when I was I was on that
Superman yeah oh man that was so Starry
Eyed God God damn I missed those days
yeah they just inspired me like crazy
especially the uh the the the cosplayers
and stuff like that yeah yeah they'll
like start the cop they'll start The
Tick Tock like without any makeup and
then they'll go take the video do their
makeup for the video as the video is
rolling and then get into the costume
all for one video and have it all just
on Tick Tock the whole time yeah like
while they're doing it I'm just like
you're just amazing you're amazing
you're glorious you're fantastic you're
Queens all of you I [ __ ] love you
you're so intense you feel like the Bob
quality has been like stepped up over
the years in terms of Cosplay definitely
think cosplay now for tick tock in
particular not talking about The
Crafting aspect yeah yeah crafting
aspect [ __ ] yes it's like accelerated as
far as like Tick Tock cosplay it's more
like you have to be the character and do
the like like you have to embody the
character yeah yeah you have to really
present yourself as like a content
creator that is also a cosplayer yeah
right right how long would you say it
takes like learn the skills that you
have or like the kind of like the
average skill level that you see on Tick
Tock or some some of like the hiring
house right because like because I feel
like a majority of people on Tick Tock
who like do the they crank out their
things and stuff are doing like purchase
costumes maybe right and then like there
are the there is the Crafters as well
who like put that stuff like I think it
takes I don't know really depends on
like yeah because I'm sure like get to
get to the skill set of like kamui for
example yeah it's like [ __ ] decades
right like just getting to the point
where you just start building your own
armor yep yeah yeah but it's also like
like some there's some really talented
makeup artists as well like yeah almost
like [ __ ] man you like this is an actual
artist I'm looking at with something
like they don't have to cost they don't
have to make a costume no no no cosplay
just with the face yeah yeah exactly
it's [ __ ] incredible you guys seen
that guy who does like the real meme
cosplays and he's like he'll like paint
his butt
I love that it's like it's the cheap
cosplay the Southeast Asian guy right
yeah oh yeah that guy that's awesome
it's actually Thai actually
shout out to my Thai bro